There's three things that divide women
and men most,
particularly from the psychometric
perspective.
One is that women are more agreeable
than men,
and so that seems to be the primary
maternal dimension as far as I can tell,
it's associated with a desire to avoid
conflict,
but it's associated with interpersonal
closeness,
compassion,
politeness.
Women are reliably higher than men,
especially in the Scandinavian countries
and in the countries where
egalitarianism has progressed the
farthest,
so that's where the difference is.
Maximize,
which is one of the things James Demore
pointed out quite correctly in his
infamous google memo.
Okay.
Women are higher in negative emotion,
so that's anxiety and emotional pain
that that difference is approximately
the same size and again that maximizes
in egalitarian societies which is
extremely interesting and then the
biggest difference is the difference in
interest between people and things and
so women are more interested in people
and men are more interested in things
which goes along quite nicely with your
car anecdote,
but the thing about men interacting with
Matt and again is that it isn't that
they respect each other's viewpoints.
That's not exactly right.
What happens with a man,
and I know a lot of men that I would
regard as as remarkably tough people for
one reason or another and everything you
do with them is a form of combat.
Like if you want your viewpoint taken
seriously,
often you have to yell them down and
like they're not going to stop talking
unless you start talking over them.
You know,
and it's,
it's not like manner automatically
giving respect to other men because that
just doesn't happen.
Instead,
the combat is there and it's expected
and one of the problems.
And so this is part of the reason why I
think men are being taken out of so much
of academia and,
and,
and maybe the academic world in general
and maybe the world in general,
is that man actually don't have any idea
how to compete with women.
Because the problem is,
is that if you unleash yourself
completely,
then you're an absolute bully.
And there's no doubt about that.
Because if men unleashed themselves on
other men,
that can be pretty goddamn brutal.
Especially for the men that are really
tough and this.
So that just doesn't happen with women,
but so you can unleash yourself
completely if you,
when you're a bully,
if you lose while you're just bloody
pathetic.
So how the hell are you supposed to play
a game like that,
you know?
So in I've worked with lots of women in
law firms and in Canada for example,
and high achieving women,
like really remarkable people I would
say.
And they're often nonplussed I would say
by the attitude of the man in the law
firm because they would like to see
everyone pulling together because
they're all part of the same team,
whereas the manner like at each other's
throats in an,
in a cooperative way because they want
the law firm to succeed,
but they want to be the person who's at
the top of the success hierarchy.
Right?
So,
and that,
that doesn't jive well with the more
competitive or cooperative ethos.
That's part and parcel of agreeableness.
And so we don't really have any idea how
to integrate male and female dominance.
And that's exactly right.
This is why I this show,
real housewives and went to,
which is more sentence scorns and just
say just last night,
okay.
I was watching an episode right where
the women were at each other.
Okay.
At a party and in,
in,
in recounting,
but I said this to you,
but you said this to me and you and the
men got.
We got together there and said,
well,
this is the way they communicate with
each other and insight in the men we
men,
okay.
Just we'll have a fistfight and wheel
him in 10 minutes later we're going to
have a beer at the bar next to each
other and so and I have observed that my
mind fire daughter,
my daughter used to be really irritated
about that because she,
she,
like most people was the target of
feminine.
Conspiratorial bullying when she's no
pushover,
my daughter.
So this wasn't like this was a continual
thing or that she didn't know what to do
about it,
but she used to observe these girls
conspiring against her and then black
getting your name on on facebook,
which is part of it,
part and parcel of the typical female
bullying routine,
which is often reputation demolition,
right?
That there's a good literature on that.
And then she'd watched what would happen
if my brother or my son would have a
dispute with his friends,
you know,
and maybe they were drinking and there
was a dispute,
they'd have a fight and then the next
day they were friends again.
And that's another thing that's strange
is that men have a way of bringing a
conflict to a head and resolving it
right.
And that it isn't the obvious to me that
women have that same.
Perhaps you might call it a luxury,
but it's also the case that men don't
know what to do when they get into a
conflict with a woman.
Because what the hell are you supposed
to do?
You know?
Mostly what you're supposed to do is
avoid it.